Well, let's take a look together.
Could we have seen 0 tokens so far?
No, when we've seen 0 tokens the red dot has to be really far to the left.
Currently, the red dot suggests that we've already seen an E and a +.
The + alone takes up 1 token, so we can't be here.
Alright, but could we have just seen 1 token?
Well, since we've seen an expression and a + and the smallest expression is itself,
1 token, we need to have seen at least 2, so we can't be here.
However, we could have seen just 2 if the input so far was INT +.
We've seen 2 tokens and one of our states would be exactly this one.
INT reduces to, or can be rewritten from, E using one of the rules in our grammar.
The + is a terminal, so it always stays the same.
Here's where we are.
How about 3?
Well, this is a little trickier.
In our grammar, if we had seen 3 input tokens, our red dot wouldn't be right here
after the +, it would be over one more.
Something a little different would happen.
It's very hard to have a string in the language of this grammar,
where after 3 tokens you've just seen a +.
But surprisingly, 4 tokens does.
Let's make a little room and take a look and see why.
E can be rewritten by INT. E can be rewritten by INT.
This + stays the same.
So the 3 of these together, E + E are themselves--one more E.
So conceptually from the parsers point of view,
what we've seen so far is an E and a +, assuming we've done all these rewrites
over here on the left, and we're looking for a little more input.
So in fact, we could have seen 4 input tokens INT + INT +
and been in this parsing state.
This might seem a little counterintuitive but remember the glory of parsing,
or the glory of context-free grammars, is that a very concise grammar notation
stands for an infinite number of strings.
Even this very simple grammar has an infinite number of strings in its language,
so it shouldn't be surprising that longer strings than 2 can have very concise parse states.
5 tokens isn't going to work for the same reason that 3 tokens didn't work.
The dot would have to be in another place.
However, if we were to add a few more INTs, this trick that I've done here
of reducing INT goes to INT goes to INT--if I had 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 tokens,
I could also be in the same state.
So 2, 4, 6, 8--the pattern repeats.